[موسيقى]
غداه هجمات صاروخيه على اوكرانيا اليابان
تفرض قيودا على صادرات عشرات المؤسسات
الروسيه
هدوء حذر في غزه بعد غارات الاسرائيليه
واطلاق صواريخ من القطاع باتجاه مستوطنات
حدوديه
مطالبات في واشنطن بمحاسبه النظام
الايراني ومؤتمر في بروكسل لمناقشه
الانتفاضه الشعبيه في ايران
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
الى هذه النشره جددت اليابان العقوبات على
روسيا في اعقاب احدث موجه من الهجمات
الصاروخيه في اوكرانيا واضافت اليابان بعض
الصناعي الى قائمه حظر التصدير تشمل حظر
شحنات مواد الى 49 مؤسسه فضلا عن تجميل
اصول ثلاثه كيانات واثنين فردا في روسيا
من بينهم ميخائيل
وزير الدفاع
مؤيدا لموسكو
وغداه اعلن واشنطن وبرلين عزمهما على
تزويد كييف دبابات ثقيله تعرضت كييف
ومناطقه اخرى لقصف صاروخين روسي او قاعه
11 قتيلا و11 جريحا على الاقل وذلك بحسب
ما افادت المتحدثه باسم اجهزه الاسعاف او
المتحدثونر خرينجي من جهته اعلن القائد
العام للقوات الاوكرانيه المسلحه
ان الدفاعات الجويه دمرت اربعه سبعه
واربعين صاروخا عابرا 20 منها قرب العاصمه
كيف كذلك اعلنت اوكرانيا اسقاط 24
والطائره مسيره ايرانيه الصنع من طراز
شاهد ليله امس
نشير الى هذا العاجل مشاهدينا امامكم على
الشاشه حيث تقول وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
بانها تمفي تحقيق روسيا اي تقدم جوهري في
دنيتك وزابريجيا وفي عوده الى سياق نشرنا
ممثل الامين العام للامم المتحده ستيفان
دوجيرك قال ان قرار الغروب بتزويد
اوكرانيا بالدبابات لا يمثل خطوه نحو
السلام ولا يسير في الاتجاه الصحيح
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا ما نريده هو السلام والعدل
في العالم وفقا لمثاق الامم المتحده
والقانون الدولي ما نراه الان لا يقودنا
الى اي اتجاه لكن في نفس الوقت لا يمنعنا
من تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بعد الفراجات التي شهدتها طلباتكييف
للدبابات الالمانيه والامريكيه عين القوات
الاوكرانيه حاليا على مقاتلات اف 16 في
مقترح الدوله الاوروبيه
محرمه دوليا الى اوكرانيا لمساعدتها في
ساحه المعركه
العسكريه البريه لتدعيم هجمات القوات
الاوكرانيه
حيث تدور محادثات حول نقل طرف ثالث
لطائرات اف 16 اي اعاده بعض الدول
استعدادها لتلبيه الطلب وفقا لصحيفه
اف 16 او الصقر المقاتل طائره مقاتله
نفاثه احاديه المحرك خفيفه الوزن ومتعدده
المهام صممت مشاهدينا كطائره قنص خفيفه
وتطورت لمقاتله هجوميه دقيقه الاصابه
للاهداف ولديها طبعا قدره كبيره على
المناوره في الساحه تم انتاج حوالي
4,540 طائره اف 16 ولم تعد تشتريها القوات
الامريكيه لكن الانتاج مستمر لاغراض
التصدير مناقشات الاف 16 تتزامن مع اقتراح
دوله اوروبيه لم يكشف عن هويتها بعد ارسال
ذخائر
هذه الذخائر محرمه دوليا وفقا معاهده
امميه وقعتها معظم الدول الغربيه باستثناء
روسيا كما هو معلوم فهي تنثر مشاهدين عددا
كبيره من القنابل الصغيره المتفجره وغالبا
طبعا ما تشكل تهديدا لفتره طويله حتى
انتهاء النزاعات لكن الدوله المجهوله حتى
اللحظه تشادل بان القنابل العنقضيه اسلحه
مشروعه فاضرار هذه القنابل الجلبيه جانبيه
لم تعد كبيره كما في السابق ويمكن التحكم
بها بشكل كبير وفق تعبير هذه الدوله
المجهوله وللمفارقه بان شحنه القنابل
العنقضيه هي الاخرى بحاجه لضوء اخضر
الماني لمشارتها في الانتاج كما حصل مع
دبابات
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريه
زخرفه دعاه سفيره المانيا لتوضيح الالتباس
الظاهر في موقفي وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه
بخصوصي صفقه المانيا في الحرب في اوكرانيا
على حد قولها زخرفه اضافت ان وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه تعلن ان بلادها مع دول
اخرى في حاله حرب مع روسيا وفي نفس الوقت
لا تعتبر نفس هذه الوزاره بلادها طرفا في
النزاع باوكرانيا في وقت سابقا قالت وزاره
الخارجيه الالمانيه ان تقديم الدعم الى
سلطات كيف لا يجعل المانيا طرفا في النزاع
في اوكرانيا
مشاهدينا في عجل يريدنا من الخارجيه
الاذربيجانيه تقول ان الهجوم على سفارتنا
في طهران الدالي مقتل رئيس فريق الامن
واصابه اخرين اذا الهجوم على السفاره
الاثريه في طهران ادى الى مقتل رئيس فريق
الامن واصابه اخرين بحسب الخارجيه
الاذربيجانيه عدد هدوء الحذر الى قطاع غزه
فجر اليوم
فنشر الجيش الاسرائيلي فيديو ويوفق تلك
الغرامات التي نفذتها طائراته لنفقين تحت
الارض في غزه تم استهدافه بيانا للجيش
الاسرائيلي وكانت مصادر امنيه في حماس
ذكرت ان اسرائيل 15 غار على القطاع بينما
اعلنت كتائب القسام انها تصدت للمقاتلات
الاسرائيليه بصواريخ ارض جو بمضاداتتها
الارضيه
معنى من القدس مراسله العربيه لنا كالغاسي
اهلا بك معنا لنا اذا بعد هدوء حذر كيف هي
الاوضاع هناك الان
صباح الخير فاطمه نعم يعني نحن نتحدث عن
اوضاع متوتره بلوى متوتره جدا يعني هناك
توتر ايضا في الضفه الغربيه راينا ايضا في
الامس شنت القوات الاسرائيليه عمليه كبيره
في جنين ما اثرت الى ارتقاء اكثر من او
تقريبا عشر فلسطينيين في المخيم اليوم نحن
نتحدث عن التوتر ايضا من قطاع غزه حيث
هددت فعليا امس الفصائل الفلسطينيه الجيش
او القوات الاسرائيليه بانها سوف ترد على
المجزره التي تم احداثها في جميع
الامس فعليا
فقامت فعاليه الفصائل الفلسطينيه باطلاق
صواريخ من قطاع غزه الى اسرائيل فعليا همم
حوالي قرابه الساعه الواحده همم فعليا بعد
منتصف الليل واقامت ايضا القوات
الاسرائيليه
بارد على هذه العمليه وافقت صواريخ اا وهي
فعليا ادعت انها اعترضت القبه الحديديه
صواريخ من قطاع غزه حوالي الساعه 3:30
وكان ايضا هناك انذارات في مناطق مختلفه
في عسقلان وهمم مناطق باسرائيل وتقول
فعليا ان اسرائيل ردت على هذا الهجوم من
قطاع غزه ب همم هجوم اخر على مواقع لانتاج
الصواريخ ومعسكر ايضا
لجيش تابع لحركه همم حماس وفعليا يعني
تقول اسرائيل انها سترد بالفعل بل وسترد
اكثر ان همم استمرت الفصائل الفلسطينيه
بهذه التصعيدات اذن هل نتوقع المزيد من
التصعيد لان بحسب ما تقولين يعني
نعم يعني نتوقع مزيدا من التصعيد فعليا
خاصه بعد يعني اعلان ايضا السلطه
الفلسطينيه بانها سوف تقوم بقطع او فعليا
همم التنسيق الامن مع القوات الاسرائيليه
وهذا ايضا يعني سوف يشكل توتر في الضفه
الغربيه بجانب التوتر الموجود حاليا في
قطاع غزه سوف يعني نحن نتحدث عن التوترات
موجوده في جميع الاراضي اليوم اليوم
الجمعه اعلنت ايضا الفصائل همم بانه سوف
يكون جمعه غضب ومن المتوقع ان يكون ايضا
هناك يعني اشتباكات مع القوات الاسرائيليه
تقول الفصائل الفلسطينيه بان الاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه هي تستمر خاصه في الضفه
الغربيه سواء في جنين او في نابلس وترد
ايضا
النعوات الاسرائيليه بالمثل فا يعني سوف
نشهد توترات في يعني معظمها سوف تكون في
الضفه الغربيه والقدس ايضا في ربما باحات
المسجد الاقصى وايضا في قطاع غزه شكرا لك
من القدس مراسله العربيه لناك الغاصي
[موسيقى]
استهداف كتيبه 13
الغربيه
دوامه العنف الضفه فيما عربه الخارجيه
الامريكيه عن قلقها من التصعيد وطالبت
كافه الاطراف بخفض التوتر وتعاوني لتحسين
الاوضاع الامنيه وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان هناك تحديات امنيه شديده تواجه
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
مشرعون امريكيون يدعون لاتخاد موقف اكثر
صرامه مع الصين
احييكم من جديد اكد رئيس لجنه مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي للعلاقات الخارجيه
ان الولايات المتحده بحاجه الى اثاره قضيه
النظام الايراني للمحتجين في كل المنتديات
الدوليه كما فعلت في مجلس الامم المتحده
لحقوق الانسان وطالب واشنطن والحلفاء
بالاستمرار في فرد العقوبات على النظام
الايراني كما حذر الولايات المتحده
والمجتمع الدولي من التزام الصمت كما يحدث
في ايران من سفك دماء المتظاهرين
من جانبه اشار كبير الجمهوريين في لجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي
السناتر عبر تغريده على موقع تويتر الا
انه بعد مقتل مهساه امين يحتاج الايرانيون
على وحشيه النظام واظهر رغبتهم في المزيد
من السلام والحريه في ايران واعتبر ريش
انه يجب على الرئيس الامريكي بدل المزيد
للمساعده في انهاء اضطهاد النظام الايراني
للنساء ومحاسبه منتهك حقوق الانسان
نبقى في ايران حيث ادرى محتجونا النار في
احد مقرات الفسيخ في الاحواز كما احرقوا
صوره لقاسم سليماني في كاشمر في خراسان
[موسيقى]
تجتمعوا مجموعه واسعه من الشخصيات بمنفيهم
نواب وسفراء وكبار المسؤولين السابقين من
مختلف الدول العربيه وذلك في مؤتمر في
بروكسيل لمناقشه الانتفاضه الايرانيه
واستمرارها لاكثر من اربعه اشهر وافاق
حدوث تغييرات جوهريه في ايران ويناقش
المشاركون في المؤتمر وهو الاول من نوعه
يناقشون السياسه الاوروبيه تجاه ايران
وضروره ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني على
قائمه الارهاب
حضر بول تشيستر المسؤول في المركز القومي
للامن السبراني الملحق بجهاز الاستخبارات
والامن البريطاني حذرا من ان قراصنه
معلوماتيه ايرانيين وروسا يهاجمون بلا
هواذا صحفيين وشخصيات سياسيه بريطانيه
ومؤسسات من اجل سرقه البيانات وتعريض
الانظمه الحساسه للخطر
فرضت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات على
الرئيس السابق للبراغواي هوراسيو كارترز
ونائب الرئيس الحالي
بالمساهمه في تفشل فساد بما يقوض المؤسسات
الديمقراطيه وادرجه الوزاره ايضا اربعه
كيانات يسيطر عليها كارتيس في القائمه
السوداء
دعم فرعون امريكيون اداره الرئيس جوبيدن
الى موقف اكثر صرامه مع الصين بعد
التهامهم لشركات الكبرى في بكين بدعم
روسيا في حربها مع اوكرانيا وقدما عضو
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
اشباه الموصلات لتوجيه الصواريخ مضيفا ان
اختباء الصين وراء شركاتها لن يبعد
احتماليه فرض عقوبات ضدها على حديقه
مسؤول في البيت الابيض اعلن ان العمليه
الخاصه في الصومال والتي امر بها الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ادت الى مقتل القيادي
في داعش بلال السوداني و10 عناصر اخرين من
التنظيم وذلك على جبال كالمسكاد شمال
الصومال واستهدفت الغاره الجويه الامريكيه
معسكرات التدريب ومخابئ داعش والمتميركزه
في تلال منطقه باري في بوتن لاند
اكدت المعارضه التركيه ان ترشح الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان لمنصب الرئيس الاماراتي
الثالثه مخالف للدستور وقال بيان للطاوله
السداسيه ان زعماء سته احزاب معارضين
يناقشون اليه اختيار مرشح مشترك للمعارضه
ولفته الى انهم توافقوا على خطه المرحله
الانتقاليه في حال فازت المعارضه
بالانتخابات القادمه
في تركيا قاده سته احزاب معارضه يجتمعون
للمره ال 11
تحضيرا للانتخابات القادمه
بيان المعارضه بعد الاجتماع اكد ان ترشح
اردوغان لمنصب الرئيس للمره الثالثه
مخالف للدستور ما لم يحظى بموافقه
البرلمان رغم تاكيد مؤيد الائتلاف الحاكم
ان احزاب المعارضه تنشغل بقضاء كشرعيه
انتخاب اردوغان والمرحله الانتقاليه
والتحول الى النظام البرلماني لعجزها عن
اختيار مرشح مشترك ترا اوصات المعارضه انا
الطاوله السداسيه انما تعمل على تحديد
معايير واضحه ومحدده للرئيس مع صلاحياته
تعزز التجربه الديمقراطيه دون وجود خلاف
حول شخصيه اردوغان
قال طول مس سعيده
يكون لهم مرشح سيكون هناك امور عديده
للنقاش منها مرشح الرئاسه ونائبه وكيف
ستدار هذه الفتره يعني كيف ستشكل
التحالفات للاحزاب او وضعها بعد
الانتخابات يجب ان تتوضح تلك الامور
المرشح المشترك للمعارضه هو الملف
والخلافي الابرز ولا توافق حتى الان على
شخصيه مرشح لكن البيان اشار الى انهم
توصلوا الى اتفاق حول خطه العمل في
المرحله الانتقاليه قبل التحول الى النظام
البرلماني اذا فازت المعارضه بالانتخابات
مرشح مشترك هذا الذي يقوم به بعد هذه
الخطوه سيقومون بالتحضير للنظام البرلماني
وبعدها يمكن حينها اختيار المرشح للرئاسه
ونائب الرئيس
ووافقه مصادره مطلعه فان خيارات عده
يناقشها قاده الاحزاب السته حاليا من
بينها ان يكون للرئيس خمسه نواب هم بقيه
قاده الاحزاب في الطاوله السداسيه وطرح
اخر يقترح ان يكون الرئيس من حزب الشعب
ونائبه من حزب الخير وبقيه الاحزاب يكون
لها وزارات في الحكومه
اسابيعهم قليله فقط للانتخابات وقضيه مرشح
المعارضه ما زالت تشغل الشارع وفي رايك
كثيرين ان تاخر المعارضه اكثر او فشلها في
اختيار مرشح مشترك انما يصب في مصلحه حمله
اردوغان الانتخابيه لتماسك وعسكره في
مقابل عدم الاتفاق في المعسكر الاخر زيدان
زينجو العربيه اسطنبول
افادت مصادره للعربيه ان عمليات البحث لا
تزال جاريه من قبل السلطات الامنيه في
الولايات المتحده عن نيكول ميري وهي فتاه
امريكيه تبلغ من العمر 19 عاما ومتهمه
بقتل الطالب السعوديه المبتعث الوليد
الغريبي دول ال 25 عاما
يوم الاثنين الماضي كان هذا المنزل مسرحا
لعمليه قتل رحب ضحيتها طالب السعودي وليد
25 عاما قتلته نيكول ميري الامريكيه هذه
19 عاما تفاصيل الحادث ترويها لنا صاحبه
المنزل التي وجدت وليد غرقا في دمائهم في
الطابق الثالث تحديدا في الحمام صاحبه
المنزل تم استدعائها على عجل من قبل
القاتلين الاخرين للمنزل قالوا لها بانهم
يسمعون صوت لبدات مخنوقه لا يعرفون مصدرها
وصلت صاحبه المنزل على عجل وجدت نيكول
ميري تنظف بطريقه غريبه تشاجرت هي واياها
وعلى الفور لكل ميري تركت المنزل
دخلت الى سيارتها واقلعت
هنا صاحبه المنزل
حاولت ان تطلع على ماذا لا يحصل تحديدا في
الطابق الثالث وجدت باب الحمام مقفولا
حاولت بكل الطرق ان تفتحه وفي النهايه
نجحت
لتجديد غارقا في دماؤه في هذا الحمام
يصارع ويلفض نفس انفاسه الاخيره حاولت
الاتصال بالشرطه وبعد 10 دقائق تحديدا
وصلت الشرطه لتعلن وفاه وليد عند الساعه
11:00
صباحا 51 دقيقه
لانه هو طيب الاقتصاد الاردني وتماشيا مع
رؤى التحديث السياسي والاداري للدوله
اعلنت الحكومه الاردنيه عن اقامه مشروعا
وطني وابعاد الاقتصاديه واجتماعيه
يحاول امين اختصار الوقت والمسافه لكن
حاله الازدحام والاقتضاض في العاصمه عمان
باتت مشهدا يتكرر كل يوم حال امين لا
يختلف عن حال خمسه ملايين شخص حجت بهم
عمان وما بين ضغط على البناء التحتيه
والخدمات ثمه امل بمساحه جديده للسكن بعد
اعلان الحكومه بناء مدينه حديثه تحاكي
احلام كثيرين كل يوم الصبح بس اجي اطلع
يعني الازمه دائما بتواجهني فعليا لو انه
المنطقه الاداريه يكون فيها كافه الطرق
سالتك والامور تكون انا ما عندي مشكله
طبعا اكيد اني برحل تقع المدينه الجديده
بين عمان والزرقاء كمدن كبرى تعاني من
الضغط السكاني وتبدا اولى مراحلها عام
2025 وتنتهي في اقل من 10 سنوات بقدره
استيعابيه تصل الى مئه وخمسه وسبعين الف
سنه ومع انتهاء المرحله الاخيره عام 2050
يصل عدد سكان لمليون شخص يمكن انشاء مدينه
جديده
سيكون اقل كلفه من اصلاح البنا تحته كامله
في مدينه متسعه مثل العمال ثانيا عمان
توسعت بحيث انها يعني
احتلت مساحات كبرى بما فيها الاراضي
الزراعيه في وقت يرى كثيرون اولويه
الاتجاه لتطوير المدن الحاليه وبنيتها
التحتيه التي يعاني منها المواطن اضافه
للكثير من المشاريع المعلقه لابد من اعاده
قراءه اا الموقع واعاده قراءه ماذا نحن
نحتاج حقيقه لحل المشاكل التخطيطيه
والعمرانيه
للمدن الاردنيه وبلغه الارقام تصل تكلفه
المرحله الاولى للمدينه الجديده اكثر من
400 واربعين مليون دينار خصصتها الحكومه
من الموازنه العامه التخفيف من الضغط
السكاني اول ده في المدينه الجديده التي
ترى فيها الحكومه تحلا اقتصاديا في ظل
ازمات يواجهها الاردن الا انها كانت براي
اخرين تحتاج لحلول اخرى تنجز في وقت سريع
وبتكلفه اقل بكثير عماد العضله الى
العربيه عمان
في الختام الى العناوين
[موسيقى]
غداه هجمه صاروخيه على اوكرانيا اليابان
تفرضوا قيودا على صادرات عشرات المؤسسات
الروسيه
هدوء حذر في غزه بعد غارات الاسرائيليه
واطلاق صواريخ من القطاع باتجاه مستوطنات
حدوديه
مطالبات في واشنط بمحاسبه النظام الايراني
ومؤتمر في بروكسل لمناقشه الانتفاضه
الشعبيه في ايران
في امان الله
[موسيقى]